previously on the flash they put the
Dark Matter there must be affected me
somehow hey everybody its charlie
we got a whole bunch of comic book stuff
coming up on the flash stuff that people
have been asking for danielle Panabaker
tease the next couple of episodes she
actually confirms a couple of other
details - then I'll explain what's going
on because there are a couple things
that they're doing the people have been
asking for for a long time there is a
new round of that blasts ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so here's that video from danielle
panabaker 15 is gonna be a really cool
episode it's something we've never done
before it's a really cool idea 16 is
great 17 is the episode we're filming
right now that Kevin Smith is directing
we have a table read for episode 18
tomorrow
being directed by returning favorite
Hana Lee so we're keeping busy but
they're definitely catching up you guys
watch them so quickly you guys watch the
episode faster than we can make them
doing more crossover episodes I don't
know I feel like later in the season we
tend to have like a little pop over
cross effort crossover episodes where
it's just one person I'd like to see
more of that in the upcoming season I
mean guys we gotta fight the thinker
he's uh he's two steps ahead of us we're
getting close to finding all those buste
menace though um tornado twins I don't
know the tornado twins are well Goldberg
be coming back um I think his storyline
wrapped up really well I actually
watched episode 12 I thought it was
great I thought it was actually one of
our stronger episodes so I think I
really like the way his storyline ended
well killer frost go back to being on
the bad side I would like show more
about that myself I would like to know
what makes killer frost so bad and I
hope we get to explore that a little bit
more um let's see any more good Caitlin
and Cisco stuff coming up um antenna in
the episode we're filming right now
which is episode 17 there's some good
stuff with Caitlin and Cisco I always
want more of that well let's see well
they do any more of the Rogues I don't
know about the Rogues I feel like you
know a few of them are busy over on
legends so yeah so thank you guys for
popping by asking some questions so a
lot of funny stuff in there she
corroborates some information that we
have about the next couple of episodes I
think it's funny that she doesn't know
who the tornado twins are I usually
don't expect the actors to understand a
lot of really deep mythology because a
lot of times the TV show will change
stuff so we can mess with their heads a
little bit if they're performing for
where the character ends up and not
where they're supposed to be in each
episode so like there's an emotional arc
that they have to track so it's not
always important that they know what's
going to be happening next you also
probably detected that she's sidestepped
that question about season five like oh
we got the thinker now we have to worry
about this happening right now but she
does smile a little bit so they're all
pretty solid that everybody is coming
back but when she says episode 15 is
something cool that they've never tried
before based on what the actors have
been talking about that sounds like it's
going to be their flash family episode
and it's something that I've been asking
for for a long time but logistically
it's a little harder to pull off because
it's more expensive you have to pay more
actors and if they really are gonna put
a lot of them together on screen then
you want them to be using their flash
powers like you would see when they were
on Young Justice together or the other
animated series from a production
standpoint it's just a lot harder to
pull off but that sounds like the
episode that Jay Garrick and Jesse quick
are coming back for that will lead
directly into the run iris run episode
so it sounds like whatever is happening
with Iris there are a lot of theories
about her being pregnant this being Dawn
West and her being in this flash moment
with Barry because of her powers and
that whole thing was Cecile getting
powers because of her pregnancy being
foreshadowing for something similar
happening to iris it is because if she
were pregnant she would have Barry's
speedster children inside her so her
pregnancy powers would be more specific
to the Speed Force she kind of brushes
past episode 16 but we've all seen the
pictures we know that's gonna be the
speedster iris episode we don't know
exactly how long she's going to have
those but they made it sound like it's
gonna be a relatively quick thing so
maybe less time than Cecile has had
telepathy powers I'm guessing that she's
only gonna be in that costume for that
one episode and then there might be some
After Effects in episode 17 but whatever
is going to happen to give her those
actual Speed Force powers it will
probably happen at the very end of
episode 15
so then you've also probably seen Kevin
Smith on the set filming his episode
it's 17 this year he posted this picture
of elongated man so I know you've all
had the theory about the thinker
stealing his powers to give himself his
old body back he looks fine in this
episode so if that's gonna happen it's
not gonna be till later in the season
but then he also posted this picture
from behind the scenes with Neil
salyanz' in the chair with this crazy
long beard unless he's getting ready to
go to hair and makeup to shave off that
beard and film an actual scene with him
in the thinker costume the only other
reason for him to be on set is to use
him as a reference for stuff that
they'll do voice over for later like it
becomes more of a mindspace thing where
his wife thinks she's speaking to the
original version of the thinker then
later they just add him with a little
bit of special effects and voice over so
he hasn't fully reclaimed his body yet
because remember it's episode 17
elongated man is walking around freeing
clear
but technically it's still Neil salyanz'
mind in these other people's bodies she
also says during that episode there's
gonna be a lot more Caitlin and Cisco
scenes they haven't spent a whole lot of
time together there's a lot of fun
pairings that you haven't seen a lot of
this past season just because of the
storylines that they're doing like
they're obviously
teasing iris eventually getting pregnant
so they can do speedster children they
can get to bar down so most of Barry's
scenes have been with iris for the last
couple of episodes especially since he
just got out of prison in a lot of Cisco
scenes have been group scenes with
elongated man Harrison wells and Caitlin
there haven't been a lot of those
Caitlin Cisco scenes from way back in
season 1 how bad can a birthday party be
um my folks think Donte stink don't
stink doesn't matter how much he screws
up or how many times he gets into
trouble in their eyes he can do no wrong
and yet they never fail to remind me
that I can do no right she confirms that
they're gonna be going deeper into
killer frost we'll find out why she's so
evil I've always had a problem with the
way the writers portray that character
just because she shouldn't be evil or
different from Caitlin her mind
shouldn't change when her powers are
active it is a bit of a bummer but she
does kind of confirm that Goldberg isn't
coming back but he got that 2 episode
arc which was way more than I expected
when he came on the show I just expected
him for that one episode and then maybe
come back later in the season but they
turned it into a much bigger thing in
episode 12 so really important stuff
remember flash comes back on the 27th so
it's still on break next week they'll
probably be some more footage for
episode 14 so of course I'll still do
bonus videos so let me know in the
comments which future episode are you
guys most excited about flash family
just sounds really badass and I know
everybody's waiting for copy shop girl
to come back we don't know when she's
coming back but she does have to come
back later this season just because they
left things with a pretty big
cliffhanger there Allen always pays
writing speed for symbols very clearly
building towards a big reveal but a lot
of times that's why they don't reveal
the future episode titles because that
can give that away like during season
one when episode 9 was titled the man in
the yellow suits you're like oh Li
they're doing reverse flash so what'll
happen is is I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post new DC there's a
bunch of other stuff happening today as
long as you have alerts enabled you
should see all the videos so you can
click here for the trailer for next
week's flash and you can click here for
brand new spider-man and infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight